foreign
uh welcome to this meeting of the baby
licensing regulatory committee
i am councillor sue carpendale vice
chair of the licensing and regulatory
committee and i'll be chairing the
meeting today
i will now ask the government officer to
read out the domestic arrangements
please can
thank you chair
please ensure that you maintain social
distance from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you are
seated
or if you're exempt from doing so and
that you use the hand sanitizer and
wipes provided
you'll be invited to speak and ask
questions by the chair please do not
interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please ensure mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
additionally we'll be using the e-voting
on the modern.gov app for this meeting
please good members therefore ensure
they are logged in and ready to use the
app i would like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be recorded except
where there are confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being recorded by
entering this meeting as a speaker you
are also consenting to being recorded by
the council and to the possible use of
those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
thank
you we'll do some introductions um and i
think if we start with officers who are
behind me can we perhaps move from my
left across to the right
thank you sir i'm nigel dulu i'm the
legal advisor to the subcommittee
i'm jan robertson i'm the deputy
monitoring officer and corporate manager
for democratic services
karen sarah governor
[Music]
david price licensing officer
catherine green licensing officer
emma richbelt assistant manager food
safety and licensing
kay sanders licensing officer
we don't can't see will behind me hi
thank you
let's move to the agenda then please
members um can i have apologies for
absence please
thank you chair we've received apologies
from councillor ayers councillor
creswell councillor gould
councillor grandin and councillor newman
thank you
are there any declarations of interest
members
no thank you
uh we moved to item three blr 21-3 to
confirm minutes of the meeting held on
the 11th of june
um
three of us missed that meeting um i'm
not quite sure how this will go with the
voting but um
can i have a proposal please
counselor mayberry and the seconder
council
nun and
can we have an electronic vote please
thank you chair councillors plea please
open the vote in the modern.gov app by
clicking the plus sign in the top right
of the agenda screen
the voting for this agenda item will now
show in blue
[Applause]
do we need to take any
manually any votes
can we take your vote manually uh yes
can you confirm the vote please
counsel nan are you able to vote
that's three votes for them um and one
abstain
and with council of beer that'll be four
thank you
uh item 4 received notification
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
number steve chair
received
and questions by councillors none
received chair thank you
so we moved to oh
yes no it's not going to guess it is
going to work madame chairman can we ask
questions
now
personally
of the chairman and which will be for
the officers really
thank you thank you very much um
i would actually like to ask why there
are so few of us here today
have the members valid um absent
team records please
thank you i think that's the right way
to put it i'm sorry if i've got it wrong
thank you
i'm aware that um a couple of the
councillors are away on holiday and one
of the councillors is not well
i don't have all the details
may i return um chairman thank you
um
i did
write to the um
the offices to suggest that perhaps
august was not
a good month to have such important
meetings and i would like to reiterate
that at the moment
because
i believe that these hackney taxi
carriage fares are very important
and that a better response from members
would have been
better
i said two betters in that sentence i'm
really sorry but what i'm trying to say
is i think it's
criticism where criticism is due and
credit where credit is due um i actually
think that um there could have been a
better response both from the officers
on my comment about
the months of this meeting and also from
members
for that
absence it's um it is pretty poor show
because the taxi trade are important
to the district and we should recognize
that in the best way possible
thank you
can we make a note of that please
yes it's noted chair thank you
[Applause]
all right so if we move to item six
blr 21.4 new hackney carriage and
private hire vehicle licensing policy
um i'll invite the licensing officer to
introduce the report to the committee
and perhaps as you do so
catherine you might
clarify the nature of the different
documents we've got attached to the
policy which i identify by seeing that
it's got the green bands on it so over
to you
uh thank you chair um
the
the item we've got before you the green
banded as as council um carpendale has
quite rightly said is the new proposed
policy
all of those with um the the darker
black banding is the is the old or what
i call the current weber labor policy
obviously it hasn't been
overridden uh just yet
so
um this report refers to the review of
the current hackney carriage and private
hire vehicle licensing policy for the
controlled zone of baber district
council
officers have undertaken an extensive
review of the current policy operating
within the district and in doing so have
attempted to align the independent
policies currently in place in both
baber and mid-suffolk the draft policy
for baba is attached as appendix a to
this report
the review has been lengthy and was
necessary due to the introduction of the
statutory standards published by the
department for transport in july 2020
the focus of the new statute to taxi and
private hire vehicle standards is on
protecting children and vulnerable
adults however all passengers will
benefit from the recommendations the
overarching aim of the statutory
standards is public protection
the licensing team's first steps were to
involve the trade in the early stages of
the policy review to engage and obtain
their ideas for the policy moving
forward this engagement involved a
virtual meeting held with the trade in
july 2020.
unfortunately due to the kovic 19
pandemic we were unable to hold a
meeting in person but many members of
the trade did attend virtually and
offered their opinions and suggestions
which were captured and fed into the
review
the changes likely to have the greatest
impact were identified and mitigated
early on in the review process and they
are as follows
removal of the requirement of plates 1
to 20 in this district being any type of
vehicle and 21 plus as wheelchair
accessible only for hackney carriages
drivers for plates 1 to 20 have incurred
an unfair revenue as this plate belongs
to the company or proprietor until they
wish to transfer
on transfer the individual sells the
plate number on at a high price and this
has led to a monopoly by certain
operators and individuals which is
unfair to other members of the trade
currently the licensing team undertake a
knowledge test however there will be a
mandatory requirement undertake the
introduction to the role of professional
taxi and private hire drivers course
the mandatory requirement to undertake
the course will have a financial
implication for drivers and operators
but will ensure that all drivers and
operators are certified and have the
correct awareness of the expectations of
their job role
as part of the review the taxi policy
must be sent out for consultation and
the statutory standards sets out who the
council should be consulting in respect
of any changes the authority wishes to
make to its hackney carriage and private
hire vehicle licensing policy
the licensing team is well versed in
consultations and has the necessary
contacts to undertake a wide
wide-ranging consultation exercise over
a 28-day period
a list of identified key consultants is
attached to this report as appendix c
once the consultation period has been
completed any responses will be collated
and the draft hackney carriage and
private hire vehicle licensing policy
may be revised in the light of
representations or comments made
any revised document will then be
brought back before the licensing and
regulatory committee at the next meeting
in october 2021 for further
consideration prior to the document
being recommended onto cabinet for
adoption
the team are aware that there are
several grammatical errors potentially
in the
in the proposed policy but all
grammatical and personalization errors
will be rectified before bringing this
matter back before the licensing and
regulatory committee on the 15th of
october
so the recommendation is that the
committee approves the draft hackney
carriage and private hire vehicle policy
document attached as appendix a for
consultation
further that the relevant officers
proceed with the 28-day consultation
period with the licensed trade general
public and other relevant stakeholders
and this concludes my report
thank you catherine um did you you had
an early question counselor maybe
um yes i did chairman thank you um i was
actually going to say considering the
importance of these documents it would
have been so much better to have them in
your hand so you can compare them side
by side and all these going backwards
and holds on the computer because after
about 10 minutes i've had enough
um so
i i do think in future that these
important documents should be printed
off i know i'm going to get the green
party and those about climate control
speak to me about this however we cannot
do our job properly without being able
to compare them
much better and we all sit here i think
we all have got a laptop
and they are not that big to read
and
i'm afraid that my years are advancing
and i think my colleagues years are
advancing we cannot go back and our
eyesight is not as good as it was
so please could we could we have them in
hard copy when there's something so
important
that that's what i was wanted to say
thank you chairman
i've got a lot of sympathy with that
comment counselor maybe
um
can i support that i mean if you're
going to make that proposal with cancer
maybe i'll certainly second it that we
ask the officers to make sure hard
copies are available because
it's no good i cannot print that amount
out before the meeting i try and scroll
down through it and we're still on
working on updates for 83 percent
so um you know it's hopeless no way can
i get to it and
the um cabinet member uh in charge is
present and that they need to take away
that there is serious concern we do need
hard paper copies made available
are you unable now
are you unable to
look at that policy document through
this discussion
severe is that what you're saying
just despite the inconvenience of
reading it on a screen are you are you
actually unable to access those papers
yeah i've got every sympathy with your
comment i've got a hard copy as well
um
what i was going to suggest to you
members is that because this is quite a
lengthy document anyway
and i'm quite sure that members have got
questions and various parts of it it
might help us if if i take it section by
section
and then you can each ask questions in
each section and i don't mind if you
want to make a comment at the same same
time but we will come to any debate
after that if you're grateful
sound reasonable i think that's a
brilliant idea chairman thank you all
right thank you
um
well let's uh let's have a look at this
document then um
any queries on uh obviously your
questions are going to go to to the to
the officer any queries on section one
in terms of definitions
all right there um
okay
on on section one well i believe that
section one that's on page
[Applause]
page 21 of the whole pack and page 7 of
the policy at the moment
which
if there's nothing on definitions then
there's the driver application
requirements in section 2. does anyone
have a question on that area
um thank you chairman um i've had to ask
for um a paper copy because
i can't get to it quick enough sorry so
i'm a bit behind
a chair uh could you when you're
referring to it an item could you refer
to the page number two it will yes i
will
classify it
thank you madam chairman page 11.22.22
um right are we still on oh
you said two
yeah and you're can you give me the
paragraph number again
um
2.22
okay thank you it's regarding the tax
checks i've never heard of this before i
assume it's something new because it's
coming in in 2022 but perhaps the
officer could just give us a brief
outline as to what that means
uh headless yeah i can answer that so
the the hmrc is asking us um in future
for all new applications
sorry in in um april 2022 the hmrc are
asking us to do um checks on all drivers
and operators um just to ensure that
they're registered with with them um
for tax reasons tax purposes
so in other words
it's checking that they're paying their
taxes like everybody else okay
another job that we have to do for the
government thank you
any other on that point
um yes on the same point surely that
should read income tax
it should read all applicants will need
to carry out an income tax check
that's a fair point
because tax i thought i thought that
when i first read it i thought we were
talking about um car tax
it could have been vehicle tax yes
we were looking to see what what
requirements the hmrc are asking for if
it is income we will amend amend the
policy as as per
um can we note that as a point for
action please
thank you
any other comments on section two yes
um yes um
this seems to be my bug there at the
moment um page 11
3.2.1 and we're talking about driver
dress code right so we've moved on to
section three yes yes if that's all
right yeah okay sorry
okay um
i just have a bit of a bug bear about
this that
driver dress code
guess clean and respectable in their
dress but please can we not have people
who are
dressed for the beach
sometimes i have
i have seen it all recently
and i think i think i've had enough of
seeing next week's
washing
legs
rather unsightly chests etcetera
etcetera so could we please make sure
that that's included as well thank you
well it's um i think it's certainly
there in 3.2 and a
point well made
obviously that will go
to consultation and hopefully we will
have some agreement from the trade on
that
anything else on
third section could i adjust in response
to that i mean
people in smart shorts and a smart
t-shirt or shirt
and even laid with the blades and shorts
can look very smart and respectable
drove in the taxi i would have thought
so
whilst i think they should be dressed
appropriately
i think you've been a bit hard thank you
um the wording does say clean and
respectable so
hopefully that will cover it
um any other questions on section three
from members
yes if i may chairman um i know it it
is completely unlawful but smoking under
on page 26 under section 3.4 smoking
eating and drinking
yes
however
should we not also put in there the
prohibition of
any undue substances because there are
so many these days
drugs glue
you name it
is that a fair point officer i might i
was actually going to ask them
the solicitor
to actually speak on that one thank you
well i'm
your commissioned chair
generally speaking if an act is criminal
by nature there's not really a necessity
to include it into a policy because
there is that statutory requirement not
to do that act in the first place so it
could be argued that it is superfluous
i hope you don't have such an
experienced counselor thank you thank
you very much
any other questions on section three
members
if not we go to section four which is
page 27 13 of the
policy additional assistance
requirements
um
i believe this is an area that has some
resonance with you counselor maybe
um
yes
absolutely i'm sorry councillor dawson
have i beaten you to it because you're
no i've been to it more council maybe
actually but you've please feel free to
go ahead sure only you're on here did
you want to go first no that's right
okay thank you
um thank you thank you very much um yes
this is something that is very close
close to my heart
assistant assistance dogs yes
wheelchair passengers yes but not all
disabled persons or those that use
disability equipment choose to use a
wheelchair and we do need to make
note of this
and i speak with lots of experience
it is surprising how these
uh
wheeled aids that my husband calls the
push me pull you just for effect
um they say they fit in any vehicle's
boot i can assure you they do not
so we need to make sure that we
we are not going to discriminate in any
form from any of those types of
um equipment that do not collapse as
fully as they are advertising
thank you
um i have a feeling um catherine that
that is covered somewhere in this policy
is that correct uh yes chair we have um
we have amended the the policy slightly
after um
the briefing with them with yourself um
it's actually been varied under
so i'm just finding the appropriate
section
under 6.22 disability access we have put
in included um
disability apparatus
as part of that um
so those those
changes where we met across this morning
but i'm not sure if they're accessible
um
as yet on
the system
can i direct you just temporarily
counselor maybe two 6.22 on page 36 22
of the policy
to see if that will deal with your
concerns
because i think other mobility equipment
it's very important that that should be
something that can be accommodated
could i interject counselor mayberry
can we give a giveaway to counselors
well i'm just going to say actually what
is one of the questions i was coming to
link it you would look at the 10.1
equality analysis
this is the council recognized the
removal of the requirement for hackney
carriage vehicles is numbered over 20 to
be wheelchair accessible vehicles could
have a negative impact
and it goes on to say
um
i think i'm understanding from that
you've got 20 which are wheelchair
accessible
and the licensing team will regularly
review the numbers
yes
so i think that's sort of saying
margaret that most of
all these people there are only actually
20 vehicles that can take wheelchair
users
unfortunately that's what i'm
understanding yeah
the comment that
you made
won't be relevant to all the other
drivers really because
if i could interject counsellors sorry
um anything over 20 is wheelchair
accessible in the baba district and for
the hackney carriages and there are
private hire that are also wheelchair
accessible
my own misunderstanding is are there 20
vehicles or is number 20 something else
um number one to 20 are what i call
normal vehicles so um 4c to vehicles so
it's not 20 vehicles it's just a number
allocated to a car
this is what's called the plate number
from yeah
so how many of those are there
so the wheelchair accessible yes um
it says you'll review it here
if you give me one moment i'll uh work
that out for you
yes
but i was thinking more of council maybe
his comment about being able to
presumably i don't know how
wheelchair accessible taxis are all sort
of they're allocated to specific taxis
aren't they
thank you may i can't see your comment
about it
or would you rather i didn't
you you can certainly comment i i think
i mean i i share these concerns and
they're ones that i've raised at
briefing am i correct in saying that her
comments not applicable to this because
people who go in wheelchairs can only go
certainly with my fault could only go
into specific vehicles
so the comments she's making about being
able to pack them in and let's say of
course they
they tend i think i'm right insane fold
away private hire
yes someone in a wheelchair would
actually make a phone call and arrange
um
taxi transport
i i think
where um some of my original concerns
were that firstly
they would do that
and it would be very difficult for them
to simply to roll up to a rank and hire
a taxi because the the hackney camps are
probably not going to be able to cope
with the wheelchair
and quite possibly the um
the saloon cars at the ordinary
hackney camps
might not have enough room in the
luggage compartment to take a zimmer
frame or a relator or or something else
i don't quite know how we get around
that but i think we we certainly need to
see what the the trade are going to come
back and say to us on those points and
also the members of the public
um who who need to be able to have some
input that's the beer you wanted to save
me
all right
um yes i i'm quite happy for this to be
informal at this point because i think
it's something we need to discuss
cancer maybe um thank you and and thank
you for your concerns and everyone
else's concerns um
i have read what it says in 4.2 about
wheelchair passengers but what i'm
trying to actually
get across to everyone as well is the
fact that
if somebody's using a
different mobility aid they may not be
able to get into a saloon car because
it's too low
it's much easier for those with
disabilities to be able to slide in and
out at a higher level so this is what
i'm trying to raise is that
it's not just the wheelchair users that
need those vehicles that are perhaps
higher off the ground or have a little
more room it's everyone who is
sadly in a position that you needs um
a mobility aid of some description they
do actually
there needs to be a certain amount of
those vehicles that are higher off the
ground and have the room for the storage
as well i think that's what i'm trying
to get over
and that's what they're saying here
accessible on 10.1 that's what they're
saying
i haven't gotten to 10.1 we've discussed
well it's on page 13 and you're at 4
if the officer has has any response to
councillor mabel's concerns there is
there anything actually that we can
do to ensure that there are
vehicles that that have
um accessibility for for ambulance
disabled shall we say
yes chair so we reworded 6.221
to vehicles which are built or adapted
for disabled passengers and their
disability apparatus under the advice of
the mobility and inclusion unit of the
department for transport is that there'd
be no restriction on access recognizing
that different vehicles may be suited to
varying operating areas so we included
the disability operators as well as the
wheelchairs to ensure that they
that we have compliant there
i'm content thank you
okay
where are we on section four any other
points on section four council dawson
one a
sorry that is 4.21 a
um on page 27
it says to carry the passenger whilst in
the wheelchair and i'm rather hoping
that sort of colloquial english
actually means to presume to push the
passenger wasps in the wheelchair
i was concerned about the use of the
word lifting frankly earlier
exactly i mean um no no taxi driver
would be expected to carry a pass
passenger would they was in the
wheelchair
but it could be just colloquial english
but i think i wonder just one that we
should correct that one word carry
remove it and
put something perhaps might be a bit
more
appropriate
i think we have concerns about that
don't we and i'm quite sure that the
trade will also have concerns
there is a section a little bit further
on i think about medical exemptions so
if
somebody's done their back in lifting
somebody and they therefore have a
medical exemption from lifting or
carrying
but nonetheless i think the the hope is
that at least um someone who is disabled
might have some assistance accessing of
it yes but nobody no taxi driver to be
honest with you would be expected to
even
taking someone out of chair into a car
would be more or less a resort
impossible
having lifted someone myself you know
it's like a dead weight
i think we've got some concerns about
the wording it is my father
with the officers i don't know um quite
what changes we might make at this point
or whether we might make those changes
after the consultation
um catherine do you want to have a
comment on that uh yes chair if if the
committee have any suggestions as to
were demanding and then obviously we
will hear those and make the necessary
amends um councilman agree i think
probably has those um available and um
if if not we can we can always make sure
we and we can change those before the
15th october
passenger so it leaves it slightly open
um
because i think some patients might
literally expect
someone to carry them and that's not
going to happen
okay
some change change to the wording um yes
cassidy um thank you yeah i've made
heavy work with this i mean the word
carry is used quite a lot with taxis uh
they they mean passengers getting in and
out the car rather than actually
carrying them i know it can be taken the
wrong way but i think
we've highlighted that i think that
should be noted see what consultation
comes back
and then we can look at it again is even
when necessary um but i think otherwise
we're going to be arguing over every
other word because this
as the officer said will come back to us
before it goes elsewhere so
those are points that um hopefully we
can minute
and we can follow up on
okay um
as we move on to section 5 members page
28 14 of the policy
any queries
on this
i have asked for a slight change of
wording on 6-1-7 at the top of page 29.
i thought to be capable of carrying not
less than was not terribly clear
so i think we're going to say either at
least or up to actually i just had one
on here regarding um 6.21 and the safety
screens yeah and i just wondered what um
i know we're past off because the 16.
um whether drivers have a sort of
obligation with following the covid
to
put screens like in the london taxis or
is that there's no obligation there is
there now
doesn't seem to be an obligation but
it's an option which would protect the
driver as well as perhaps customers and
catherine yes chair and there is no
obligation for them to put it in but if
they wanted to have one this is just
what they have to comply with in order
to have one
any other questions on section six
numbers
includes things like signage advertising
communications devices
the disability access that we've we've
touched on
quite a long section are we are we okay
on that
uh section seven
no
oh answer maybe um thank you um uh page
16 and we're talking about six
um
and
obviously it's um miners
6.5.6 and 6.5.7
um and we're talking about and child
seats
i
[Music]
i actually query this because
government legislation has changed that
um
children should be in a car seat until i
can't remember the age now but somebody
i think it's 12. younger than i because
i'm only a granny we'll know um
and i that just worries me all this
information about
must travel in the rear seats of
vehicles and an adult seat must be worn
yes it's a worry isn't it yes
oh i think our solicitor may have to
come in
mr dulu
that is an area of law that i'm not
entirely familiar with but it's
something we can clarify i will look at
that for you
yeah can can we have another look at
that i don't i don't know what we can do
about it if you want to take a child in
a taxi
yeah if i could ask um
my colleague david price on that one
those are the exemptions in law for
taxes and private hire vehicles so what
you see down there 6.56 and 6.57 are the
exemptions for
for the trade
we come back chairman
um
[Music]
my grandchildren do not live in in this
county and when we have been in a taxi
in the county where they are we actually
have to take the car seat with us
though i'm just a bit worried about that
mr dulu i think there might have to be
some research on like i said yes i will
look into that for you
i think an adult seat belt on a
four-year-old would be pretty dangerous
um
all right so we need to have another
look at that i think
thanks for raising that point
any anything else on section six
we move to section seven
hopefully it gets a little bit simpler
from this point onwards
uh
section eight
anyone
this is page 41 27 of the policy
i'm told that fire engines have been
used under certain circumstances
any questions on further questions on
section 8
can we move on to section 9
vehicle licenses procedures
for application
any questions there
part 3 section 10 private hire operator
policy
page 47 onwards
[Applause]
council here yeah nothing thank you
sorry to give back
um the
page 43
8.7
insurance mot slipping in there um
are these on display in the car that
that particular taxi
is insured
i mean because we
i've got him a taxi and i've never
really looked or thought about it but
i assume he's insured
and i i
just wonder if there is a display they
have to put up in the car i don't know
yeah i can answer that one chair um it
won't be on display in the vehicle but
what we do as part of their application
process and throughout the year is we
will um make sure that their mot and
insurance are up to date throughout the
duration of their licence so they have
to provide it to the team and we keep
that on file
so you do checks on that is that what
you're saying uh yes counselor
okay
so section 10 members
[Applause]
10.1.6 on page 47 it speaks again about
a tax check if we can make sure the
income if it is income tax it's altered
throughout the whole of the document
please thank you
and noted counselor thank you right yes
anything else on section 10 numbers
page 46
at the bottom
taxi rents
east street old market place in southern
railway station is this the amount of
vehicles
that can only park there or operate from
there
i think it's a number of spaces in it
catherine what's that
uh yeah i can confirm that it's the
number of spaces available in each of
those areas
may i comment chairman on that as well
um
that is written down here page 46
council of beer as well um that tends to
make a bit of a mockery of the amount of
taxes that we have parking along there
and they do park in the disabled areas
and i have
brought this to the attention before of
offices and i have complained to the
town council staff as well
we really need to make sure that we have
the correct
areas for this parking and if
i'm sure councillor beer will help my
memory but did we not talk about this
that there was going to be an alteration
for the taxi ranks
with
with old marketplace yes with the old
marketplace and in front of i'm going to
say boots the chemists there are other
chemists and pharmacies available but in
particularly on the market hill there we
were actually looking at the parking
facilities there
and the taxi rank was supposed to be
moved and disabled parking was going to
be
moved in front of boots i thought
i may be completely wrong but we were
actually looking at proper parking
facilities for the taxis because um and
this is not to the detriment of the taxi
trade if they are listening in
um
we were just concerned that the amount
of taxi operators there were and there
were not enough parking spaces available
for them
can i help on that uh you're quite right
councillor maybe we did have a
discussion this was before covert
um
and i don't know whether we've actually
got round to
creating it but we certainly agreed that
there would be extra spaces made
available in what i call in front of
boots just above boots on the market
hill
as additional
no that was disabled there wasn't it and
that we were going to have a a larger
area for the taxis
um and that was either kings hill or um
their existing part in front of the town
hall which i think they've already got
now
but all this was to come in with the
moving of the
sudbury bus station
at that time and it was proposed to have
some super bus stops around sudbury and
ending up on the market hill and we're
going to create extra facilities for
disabled drivers we're going to create
extra facilities for taxi ranks
as well
and i will add this
as well as keeping spaces for the
ordinary motorists
because
they need to be considered as well
and on the agenda didn't we about um
increasing taxing like spain again
we did chairman if it's the right to
come in um and and thank you and to
councillor beer for reminding me you're
absolutely right it was the bus stations
um
it just seems as though we need more of
a joined up thinking on all of this
and how how do we do it with
doing this policy
and with a parking policy
and should it not all be coming actually
together
rather than a bit here and a bit there i
think i think you're undoubtedly right i
i would like us to to try to keep to the
policy we're actually looking at at the
moment but i think if officers would
note the concerns we have about parking
generally in disabled spaces uh in that
part of sudbury and no doubt stomach and
other places as well i think that's
something we can ask perhaps if we have
it minuted and we ask for some
future thought on that
thank you chairman and also to add um
that that
we for the taxi ranks as well because we
didn't actually think that that um the
ten spaces here was enough i mean
the railway station i mean that's miles
away
really we need we need to make sure that
we've got
a sufficient number of areas for the
taxi rank yeah i
suspect that sort of is is a little bit
outside of the the policy we're looking
at at the moment but again i think it's
probably a good point we we should ask
to have picked up and considered
um
could i just follow on from that madam
chairman i think you're quite right i'd
go as far as to say that we need to make
sure
that this is noted somewhere um because
all classes
of motor car parking
in sudbury need to be looked at and i'm
afraid to say that it's very slow coming
forward and i've been on about all the
park and disabled
texas
the ordinary motorists for the last
three or four years and we're certainly
getting nowhere so any pressure you can
bring to bear on that i'd be only too
happy about it i think that's probably a
discussion for another day at the moment
but i hope that it that's what they tell
me all the time thank you man i don't
realize your hands are touching we need
to deal with the policy here at the
moment that we have in front of us but
i'm sure you've got lots of sympathy for
that point of view um officer any of the
officers wish to comment
um if i could calm cancer carpendale um
i'm aware that suffolk
county council highways are undertaking
a significant review
of the roads and some of the parking
infrastructure in sudbury um we did
one of our um
meetings either last year before we did
designate a rank but we're unable to
place the markings on that as yet until
that review has been undertaken in its
entirety so at the moment
we would like to put the rank down but
we are constrained and at present
might be one of the difficulties of
having district do something and county
do something something different
i wasn't aware the county was even doing
that at the moment but i'll take that up
with the um the cabinet member for
transport council richard smith thank
you very very good idea councillor beer
thank you
um any other comments on council maybe
um yes madam chairman um
page 46 we've got taxi ranks
sudbury
then we've got them for stone market are
there not any in hadley
evidently not
yeah
yes
surprises surprised me as well
had hadley people um perhaps don't
go to a taxi bank
but not to the point where someone's
prepared to wait for affair
are we done with section 10 members
in which case uh section 11
and bear in mind all of this is going
out to consultation hopefully with the
additions and amendments um to wording
and so on that's been suggested
anything on section 11
i think that's mainly um
sort of process
perhaps be scrutinized by the trade
kelsey maybe and
just for confirmation from the offices
and i may have completely overread it
but do we have any specific
taxi operators who
deal with
miners they i.e those under 18 only
yes so a lot of the um operators within
the district go out to tender with
suffolk county council passenger
transport
um we are asked regularly who are still
licensed in order to make sure that
their books are kept up to date but a
significant number are um that are
licensed with us do do do that as part
of their
business
um may i return
um
my question was do they only
operate for um
the transport tech that sounds terrible
um for transporting children only um and
i asked this in particular because apart
from the
um the county school
runs
we also have the specialist school runs
and i wondered if there were some that
were just completely licensed for that
only and whether we should record those
separately thank you
as far as i'm aware counsellor we don't
have any that are just solely for the
transportation of children
any further comments on that policy as a
whole members
i just had
i've obviously had a chance to ask a lot
of questions myself previously
i i'm just going to ask the officers
again we've got a list of consultes
appendix 6 page 85 of the document pack
i wondered what other districts in
suffolk
there might have been conversations with
and in what about tendering since um the
east of the county is that the district
is is quite close to the essex border
um have there been any discussions or
exchanges of views in putting this
policy together um catherine
uh yes chair um so we have um
meetings with all of the other um
councils on a regular basis and where we
discuss these matters but as part of the
review of this policy we also collated
all of them
the councils and suffix policies and
looked through those as well and
anything we felt that we wanted to add
we incorporated into the proposed policy
um
it is a mixture of our our own and other
other councils um
policies
thank you council maybe um thank you
chairman
um catherine knew i was going to come
back i'm sure um do we not as a matter
of course
actually consult with sudbury town
council because
they have taxi ranks and stone market
obviously we don't need to with hadley
because they don't have any um but
um but i'm just wondering whether we
should actually be doing that
um the item four i think does say old
baby town and parish councils
would that would that cover your query
um
yes and no
i'm specifically asking because they do
have the taxi ranks and that is why i am
highlighting it because the the amount
of
emails that parish clerks town clerks
get these days are huge and sometimes
sadly and unfortunately and through no
fault of their own some of these emails
get buried or
as i know to my own costs they don't
arrive sometimes and i'm just wondering
whether they should be highlighted
separately
thank you
uh yes chair um they will be consulted
as part of the wider consultation
process i do have quite a good
relationship with the sudbury town
council as you rightly said the the rank
space is is directly outside of their
offices and quite often they will alert
me to private hires attempting to park
on the rank um so
we can we can do a a more um
targeted consultation if the if the
committee wishes for us to do that um we
can we can make them more fully aware of
that
um yes please chairman and thank you
catherine i think that would also help
with the
with the understanding of the need for
taxi ranks as well thank you
thank you
um
we've taken quite a lot of uh comments
uh as well as questions members so is
there anything further
anyone would like to to argue for for
this item before perhaps
i can ask for a proposal
thank you um cancer beer seconded uh
councillor dawson
all right oh thank you
um
could you then just remind us of the
recommendation then please uh
thank you chair
[Applause]
recommendation 3.1
that the committee approves the draft
hackney carriage and private hire
vehicle policy document attached as
appendix a for consultation
further that the relevant officers
proceed with a 28-day consultation
period with the licensed trade general
public and other relevant stakeholders
and can we assume take it as read that
the comments that have been made will be
embodied in in that document that goes
to consultation
uh yes chair
thank you
um
perhaps we could uh move to an
electronic vote madam chairman if i may
um and
to also confirm
that the results of the consultation
will come back to us for further
discussion thank you it comes back here
yes yes yes counselor we'll come back on
the fifth i believe it's the 15th of
october october before then going to
cabinet yeah before it goes to cabinet
yep
right um
can i ask the governance officer to
conduct the vote please
thank you chair councillors could you
please open the vote in the modern.gov
app
in the voting tab the vote for this
agenda item will now show in blue
are you able to vote um
okay that's five votes for chair
thank you so that is carried
thank you members that's the long paper
to get through
um right we now move on to let's just
close that down
item
7blr2105 the gambling act
2005
statement of principles
a statutory three-year revision
and we still have our policy
frame of mind on
and who is introducing us so please and
i will be chair thank you catherine
okay
this report refers to policy setting
under the gambling act 2005.
since january 2007 local licensing
authorities have been responsible for
functions under the gambling act 2000
and flat
sorry 2005 including issuing of licenses
and permits for gambling slash gaming
premises and associated matters
section 349 of the 2005 act requires
each licensing authority to prepare and
publish a statement of the higher level
principles it will apply when dispensing
its various gambling functions
the statement of principles must by law
will be reviewed and republished every
three years or sooner if so required
this year the authority is due to
revisit the statement that has been
effect
since january 2019 and this report seeks
the approval of a suitably revised
version in order that a statutory
consultation period may then commence on
its content
the redrafted statement attached to
appendix a to this report contains
amendments from the 2019 published
version
these revisions have been collated in a
summary document and is attached to this
report as appendix b
the gambling commission revised national
guidance document to licensing
authorities originally published in
september 2015 as amended in april 2021
has influenced some of the revised draft
content when formulating the local
statement of principles revision
the legislation requires the licensing
authority to consult widely upon its
draft statement of principled document
with stakeholders before finalizing and
publishing the document in january 2022
the sixth statement shall take effect
for a three-year period from the 31st of
january 2022 through to the 31st of
january 2025 although the statement may
be revised sooner if necessary
based on an officer review of gambling
activity over the past three year period
the fee table attached to appendix c
representing the maxima which may be
charged by regulation for the various
application and process types under the
2005 act is a is proposed for approval
unaltered
costs which may be appropriated to the
fees include all aspects of
administering and maintaining the scheme
it should be noted that both favor and
mid-suffolk district councils also have
a limited base of gambling
authorizations and activity upon which
to apportion some of the cost elements
before i get to the recommendation
amendment has been made to the
recommendation it should read that the
draft revision
gambling act 2005 statement of
principles document attached as appendix
a be approved for consultation
further that the relevant officers
proceed with the commencement of a
period of statutory consultation in
accordance with the gambling act 2005
legislation and regulations
and that the table of fees attached as
appendix c for gambling act 2005
functions be adopted to take effect from
the 31st of january 2022 and that
concludes my report
thank you
well again members i think
rather than plodding through section by
section on this particular paper um
are there any questions that people
would like to put
initially to the officer
yes kelsey maybe thank you
thank you very thank you very much um
i remember this many years ago
when i was on
licensing so um i don't know whether
that was
2015 2016 something like that
and at the time we had a big discussion
on
what was classed as a minor for some of
these gambling
establishments um and what wasn't
and in consideration of the
it's not really gambling but it's
licensing premises for gaming
could the officer kindly explain to us
the law as to minors for those
establishments now please
sorry council when you say miners are
you referring to the removal of the the
miners um
clubs
no i'm actually talking about gaming
um clubs
and
the age that they are allowed in whether
they have to be supervised whether
they have to be accompanied
by an adult whether that adult has to
give
documentation that they are allowed to
have that
excuse me that adult with them etc etc
thank you
okay
i'll just pass across to my colleague
yeah if um schedule d
of the statement
that's page 47 of the actual statements
gambling activities
children and young persons
has everyone found that
do we have many of these game and
establishments the only one i know of is
in
sudbury
and um i'm assuming that's still in
operation after
covert
do you know um i know there was one in
its which but they're so sorry
all we have is six betting shops i
believe
there are six betting premises in baber
region that that's it six betting um
establishments which is like shops and
things as i would think
what about the
nightclub gaming center that we have at
sudbury
that's gaming as in um electronic games
rather than
amusements with prizes
i believe
well that's the one i'm referring to
madam chairman you know we had lots of
controversy over it and we put in lots
of restrictions um and i suppose
with this and i went in once and i saw
how well they were
conduct and you know children weren't
allowed to be there by themselves with
their foundation or that performance
but do we know anything is that still
causing sort of problems in the area
um there is there's ongoing matters of
that um process unfortunately so i can't
go into that i'm afraid councilor beer
but they they're under different
regulations for that premises as it's
not gambling as such um it's it's more
to do with um
the licensing regime
so so with gaming we're talking about
something different from gambling or
betting
so that's the separation
sorry i didn't mean to drop my badge on
the on the desk just then um
i think it would be useful for us all to
have the
the differentiation between gambling and
gaming
because
my understanding and it is very limited
i'm not a gamer um
is that a lot of these games are
actually played for
profit
now whether that profit is within the
establishment that they are
using the equipment for or whether it
isn't
and i think we do need to look at that
very carefully
and make sure that we
are keeping within the law because if
if it is for profit surely that
is gambling attached to gaining
and we should not encourage our young
people to do it
because
unless they are
suitably escorted
i'm afraid i can't quote verbatim
because my computer's just died
from the legislation but the the
difference between gambling and game is
gaming is competition you may pay an
entry fee to enter a competition it
could be the same for a sport or a match
you play in and there may be a prize to
win it that does not come under the
gambling act so
gaming is is more competition against
people rather than against odds if you
see what i mean so
it is not covered by the gaming act
there may be prize money involved but
you have to pay up front to enter
something a fixed fee if not always but
sometimes you pay to enter a competition
and then it's it's won by your skill
rather than
gambling against the odds
may i
um thank you mr dulu for that um for
that description i still think that's a
very great area
really great
not according to the gambling act
because it's not included in that i'm
afraid
we can legislate on as a district
council i i know what you mean
um thank you chairman i'm just thinking
and i will raise this in
um in a few moments
that may be another letter from me to
the home office because it's a very gray
area in my opinion thank you
any other comments on this policy
members take i'll take comments or
questions from anywhere on the
policy
and again as the officer has pointed out
we do add the word full consultation to
the recommendation
and we we have the root of this um
consultation when it comes back it comes
back to us
and then to counsel
yes chad
so we get a couple more bites at it if
we want it
that's maybe
if i'm if i may thank you i'm just just
looking at the the license and sundry
fees
um
when we're talking about a temporary use
notice is this just for gambling
are we now looking at appendix c
i haven't got a page number because it
is at the table
um i think it says page 145. i don't
apologize right it's the table you're
referring to yeah um
when it's this temporary use notice
could we have confirmation please
yes councillor um a temporary use notice
is is entirely different to that of a
temporary event notice um so yes the
temporary use is primarily for the use
for gambling
thank you
and who sets the fees can you just
the temporary use notice here is set by
by baber but i can confirm we we've
never had anybody apply for one
okay
[Applause]
to make him to make him decide if i may
um madam chairman and this is not to uh
take this into disrepute at all perhaps
we don't have enough poker players i
shall leave it at that thank you
i think he was starting at the new
industry
all right um if we're done with this
members can i have a proposal
to move this forward to consultation
councillor nunn thank you seconded
cancer beer thank you
and
if there are no other comments can we
move to the vote please
officer
thank you chair councillors could you
please open the vote in the modern.gov
app by clicking on the plus sign
and this vote should now be showing in
blue
we'll need to scroll down
[Applause]
that's five votes for chair thank you
thank you members
uh we move on to item eight
which is the hackney carriage table
affairs review
uh blr 21 6.
um can i confirm if we have mr hale with
us
ah thank you
um
at chairs discretion members if we have
questions that we think
a member of the trade could help us with
um
uh mr steve hale is here so
um
if if we come to that point and thank
you for coming mr hale
right uh well this one's been around the
block a few times members um
but we seem to have come to um
full circle in a way and i think we have
some additional papers
tabled as well this afternoon that may
or may not um help you it depends on
your mess
but they do seem to indicate
an increase certainly in the flag fair
and the
mileage rates for operators and drivers
[Applause]
and we have a revised table
in appendix a of the proposed fares
it doesn't explicitly talk about
percentages but obviously in terms of
the
increases in fares
um we're pretty close to looking at that
which we know that the trade seemed to
favor
do we have any questions at this point
for the officer
council beer
just so that we can be clear
the
table paper
of fair calculator and it's got journey
rate one sub return center to tesco
sudbury two miles is that the same
category as on page one five one of our
agenda pack where it says rate one
and they've got their 320.
is that the same category we're taught
not or not
they're they are example journeys using
the proposed tariff and the current
tariff to give you an idea of the
the increases expected so
that don't help me
rate one on our papers
they're saying um
three pounds twenty
but
the
taxi people
are saying um rate one on theirs five
pounds eighty-four is that the same
distance the same journey or not
because you know there's two pound fifty
difference
okay so and i need to know
that you see there is what's called the
flag fair so that's what you charge once
you've gone that distance
and then what we've provided to you is
the example journeys of how much
um those sorts of journeys currently
cost um in theory because we're not 100
sure on what the drivers were charging
um until recently and
we've now got proposed um what what the
proposed tariff would then be
no i'm still confused so you're saying
that the 3 pain 20 is what we
estimate
the cost would be if they were all
charging the same but you're saying that
some of them don't but they're saying
the estimated cost is 50 pounds 84.
um
[Music]
thank you chair so this report refers to
review of the current table affairs
fixed for hackney carriages operating in
the controlled zone of babe district
fares for hackney carriages in babe
district have not increased since august
2016.
officers have undertaken the statutory
public consultation exercise as
instructed by the committee at the
meeting of the 11th of june
2021
the committee will recall that the
proposed table affairs on which we have
consulted and that's the one that you
have as appendix a
that's based on proposals from drivers
operators and meter agents
and the aim is to provide an increased
income for the trade whilst ensuring
taxi travel is affordable for all and
those who are only able to travel in one
of the larger wheelchair accessible
vehicles are not
penalized
in a recent survey of use of taxis and
private hire vehicles by those with
disabilities in baber and mid-suffolk
most respondents told us that they
booked private hire vehicles for
journeys rather than use taxis
the availability of suitable vehicles
and lack of awareness that many taxi and
private hire vehicles are wheelchair
accessible were more of a concern than
affordability
the results of this survey have not
therefore influenced the proposed table
affairs but have fed into the review of
the taxi and private hire vehicle policy
which you've heard about earlier this
afternoon
it will be an operational decision for
each operator and proprietary proprietor
whether the maximums are charged as they
have the discretion to charge less if
they so wish
and a passenger is entitled to attempt
to negotiate a lesser fare
however proprietors must meter the
maximum fares permissible in the
district
maximum fares must be transparent to
fair paying passengers and should enable
operators to charge realistic fares
the consultation on the proposed table
affairs ran from the 14th of june to the
12th of july 2021.
the statutory public notice was issued
in the east england daily times 14th
june edition
a notice was posted at the council
offices and notices were placed at the
customer access points within the
district and on the babel website
the consultation documents were posted
to 234
taxi and private hire operators and
drivers
no responses to the consultation were
received from the public
one response was received from the trade
and this is included as appendix c to
this report and that was actually from
mr hale who's here this afternoon
[Applause]
officers are therefore proposing two
options for the committee's
consideration
option one that no change is necessary
to the revised table affairs fix for
hackney carriages operating the
controlled zone of baba district
option two that the committee is minded
to modify the revised table affairs
fixed for hackney carriages operating
the controlled zone of the baba district
recommendation
is that the committee consider the two
options
there will be a recommendation
recommendations to cabinet
the committee is asked following
considerations of options one and two in
the report to make a recommendation of
option one to cabinet on the revised
table affairs attached as appendix a
and the revised table affairs be adopted
whether the committee is minded to
modify the table or not
and
that the proposed table affairs is
adopted in accordance with section 65 of
the local government miscellaneous
provisions act 76
and also
to recommend a new date which is to be
set for the very table affairs to become
effective
no later than two months after the
specified date of the 1st of november
2021
this is a statutory function and the
legislation provides for recovery of the
reasonable cost of administration
inspection and supervision of the
licensing scheme
the act does not set out a specific
right of appeal where a council has
adopted a maximum table of fares for
hackney carriages however the fair table
may from time to time be subject to
judicial review
consultation and compliance with the
prescribed notice requirements mitigate
the main risks
that concludes my summary but i will do
my best to answer any questions
thank you emma um
uh i'll take councillor beer and then
cancel maybe
i still want to follow in from what i
asked earlier because
that's
even confused to be more
um
looking at page 151
if i went to
the taxi rank in sudbury
and i decided i want to go from the town
centre to tesco's which it quotes here
is it going to cost me 3 pounds twenty
according to pay with one five one or
five pounds eighty four okay that's
that's that's the difference i mean it's
a considerable difference but as long as
we're clear
and you're proposing that we accept this
one
in the papers
and yet this one here is the one that
they seem to favor so
okay can i try to explain counselor beer
yeah so so appendix say gives you the
the flag fair and that's the first price
that will appear on the meter when you
enter the vehicle and that's the
proposed table affairs that we're
recommending to you
it will be 3 pound 20 before you've gone
anywhere okay
all right now what you have on the the
three pages that have been provided to
you this afternoon
is a comparison
so
rate one is your normal day time rate
that's the first page
and what you've got there first of all
journey rate one
you've got an example journey from um
the town centre to tesco
now the five pound 84
is what you would likely pay today based
on existing table affairs for that
journey
the six pound 26 is what you would pay
if we adopt the revised table that's
before you this afternoon
we're clear so
the the bold print on one value for what
page 131 is the basic charge when you
get in the taxi yes and then obviously
the machine starts running and it could
go up to 584
but the new
limit could be 626. well that the the
five pounds 84 is what you would pay
today on the existing tariff
for that journey estimated as best we
can
this whereas the six pound 26 is what
you would pay if we adopt the revised
table
for a daytime journey
i do realize outside the normal hours
there's a couple charges thank you i've
got it clear sorry about that
you'll find on the other pages as they
are fighting different times a day in
different days of
the year yes it's it's trying to give a
comparison between
current fares and the increase that taxi
drivers will will get
council maybe
thank you and thank you chairman and can
i ask questions of anyone
including mr hale
yes thank you thank you very much um
first of all thank you very much mr hale
for coming um
to to this committee this afternoon um i
appreciate
appreciate it very much and i'm sure my
fellow members do too
um
as you know because i spoke to you i
actually walked up and down the taxi
rank
speaking to the taxi operators asking
them
if they agreed
with what was being proposed and
basically asking them to
reply
yes or no
and i note that only you have replied
but i can absolutely assure members here
that of all those taxi operators that i
spoke to there was only one who was not
in favor of an increase because i did
speak to them to um
to
and i think
i did it really to reassure them that we
were listening and that we were
interested in in the trade in the in
their business
and so
perhaps mr hale you'll take back my
thanks to those who did speak to me so
um thank you very much now my question
to you mr hale is that
um you're happy with the current
proposals
um
and i'm basically going to ask you
have you got any words of wisdom for us
on these these new fears
if you've got any further comment to
make for any of it please
um just to
um reiterate um just to go on back what
mr dumb counselor beer was saying um
it's a relatively simple process flag
rate three pound twenty for the new one
uh you're looking at eighteen pence a
mile also eight one pound eighty mile in
increments of eighteen pence
um or a period of thirty six seconds so
just to reiterate what you were saying
earlier about the run-up to tescos
there's plenty of traffic lights around
the moment it could be a little bit more
unfortunately because the meter will
continue to run
while you're running while you're not
moving
[Music]
generally speaking appreciate counsellor
maybe for coming down to see us all
along the rank i really do appreciate
that because that did give everyone a
bit of a bit of a boost in that respect
so
um
not really a lot else to add to be fair
i think we're
we seem
down at the rank relatively happy with
the proposals
um we understand it's taking a long time
to get to this point but hopefully we'll
come to the end of the
end of everything
um but i'm happy to answer answer any
other questions if anyone has anything
that they want to
add all right
may i return um
thank you mr hale i think um
that has reassured me more that that the
taxi trade um
99.9 or even 99 were were in
there is another question but i can't
ask it because it's not on this on this
paper but um but thank you for now thank
you very much
and well i think it is really because it
goes back to the taxi ranks
basically do you
may i ask
all right
okay thank you but but let's not get
let's not get too diverse
i would just ask for a yes or no as
perhaps um
do you use
would the taxi
trade like
more area for the taxi ranks
thank you
yes
thank you thank you
done
all right
um the waiting time per hour this year's
pro rata so if it's only a quarter of an
hour waiting it's obviously not going to
be the full 18 pounds or whatever
um so yes i i have one question and i
don't want to set a hair running but one
of the issues we've had in the past mr
hale
is the
difference in running costs that people
with the larger vehicles have
which is you know one of the reasons why
we we considered alternative charges
um to your knowledge
uh and i know you don't speak for
everybody but just your opinion
are people with the bigger vehicles
content
with these charges they don't feel
they're being
disadvantaged on a cost basis
um well i'm uh owner of a larger vehicle
myself and i'm but i personally am happy
with the um increases i don't think it's
too much
uh i think it's fair for the public as
well because i think if we were looking
any more it will be a little bit
difficult for them and it might become
unaffordable for some of the
some other people who do use taxes on a
regular basis
um i say personally i'm absolutely i'm
fine with the um charges
the costings of the larger vehicles
are going to be um covered i think with
the extra
extra charges and the changing of the
hours as well for the weekend working
after eleven o'clock from it's going
from twelve o'clock to six from six
o'clock to eleven to seven
so the weekends which
will help the trade we we are suffering
a little bit at the moment with a lot of
drivers who although are still licensed
have actually left the trade in the last
year and a half
it's been quite difficult um running a
business in german kobe has i can
understand a lot of people have had my
trade dropped 70 percent
over the last um
over the last 18 months it's picking up
again thankfully but
there'll be a lot of people out there at
the moment which are really struggling
and
this will give them a little bit of a
help
so which we do appreciate
thank you very much for that comment
it's very helpful
um does anyone else have any questions
for mr hale or for the officers
um
someone prepared to move the
recommendation
dr councillor beer thank you a second
cancer mayberry thank you
um
if we're done can i ask
could i just ask oh yes
just a little bit confused but um so
option one option two
um
what exactly are we voting on here which
one is the
the actual increase
option one or option two
um the option is to approve the
increases yes
we did have an option with the earlier
recommendations that we could modify
those fares should we wish to but it it
looks as if we don't wish to so it's
about approving the fares in the table
yeah am i correct in that
yes that's correct thank you chair thank
you very much
okay so we have it proposed and seconded
um can we move to the vote please
chair i believe we we need to recommend
a new date as well in little three
for the to be set for the very table
affairs to become effective is that
right um we do we need it we need a
specific date do we
it's within two months of the first of
november
so are we saying january 22 for
implementation
it does seem a long time since they've
had any kind of increase
yes i was going to suggest the first of
december to give the
um the taxi trade a bit of the lift
for their busiest time
and also there's meters and so on to be
sorted out does that allow time i think
i think previously we've allowed eight
weeks for um the trade to be advised and
have time to make the adjustments to the
meters so perhaps the first of january
i'm i'm sorry to to add confusion i'd
forgotten about that bit terribly sorry
is that okay then shall we move to the
vote
oh again another query
i'm
a little confused why is it the first of
november
hmm
so we're not in september yet was it
cabinet
chair this is a recommendation to
cabinet
so we're kind of waiting on cabinet i
think
obviously
[Music]
can i just clarify so you're actually
recommending to cabinet these these
options and cabinet will consider them
on the 1st of november that's hence why
the date of the 1st of november
sorry can i just clarify that and the
the date of the 1st of november was set
um as
the mata is going to be considered in
september
cabinet
so we i think the the way it's written
probably isn't quite right but we were
hoping that it would come into effect by
the first of november uh 2021 uh or they
all have to have had this
variation done to their meters by the
first of november
does that clarify
no it doesn't
i think it makes a little more confusing
if if the meters are done by the first
of november why would they need to wait
until the first of january to implement
them but they can't can it i'm sorry i
probably caused more confusion than
clarification because i forgot when you
said okay it's cabinet in september
so that would enable us then to if
cabinet agree to adopt the new revised
table affairs to then actually tell the
trade so they could start with the new
tower from the first of november so i
think we've probably slightly confused
the wording i apologize
um
so the new fares will come in on the
first of november
if the committee are minded to recommend
that yes and if cabinet agreed
correct yes thank you chair
right so
the christmas will have that uplift
and chairman i think number three needs
re wording
just be completely clear may i suggest
that uh recommend a new date
of the 1st of november
to become effect or to become effective
on the 1st of november
is that that's acceptable is that
acceptable yes and uh kat sabir you and
councillor mayberry are you both happy
with that happy with that
right i hope my problem's up right have
we have we got that noted as a change to
that um recommendation
yes we have chair
right
okay now can we move to the vote
chairman i was just going to ask if mr
de lou is happy with that
for me it's more of a pragmatic issue
rather than a legal one provided you
know that all the um that the fares and
then the meters can be amended
it's not really a problem
wait for you to put it up on the screen
then
thank you chair councillors you can now
open the vote in the modern.gov app the
vote for this item should now show in
blue
[Applause]
and
if i may definitely definitely confirm
because it says as read out to be
approved and that is from the first of
november
yes
okay thank you
thank you very much i i think we also
will need to take account of if cabinet
agree to that but that is our
recommendation of cabinet
thank you
that's five votes for chair
thank you very much
um thank you members um
before i actually close the meeting
formally um just like to thank mr hale
for coming and sharing his knowledge
with us
i think a couple of other thank yous as
well i'm not sure if you've still got
david you've never got david with us
um thank david he has been seconded to
another area
of the organization so we thank him for
his
past help to the committee and
i'd also like to thank karen karen sayer
because
she is now going to be looking after the
civic office rather than looking after
us so
thanks to karen as well
thank you members uh formally closed the
meeting at um
1608. thank you very much for your
contributions
you